and my view is that covet is being used
as propagation for a control system I
Believe by who I don't think it's so
much about a cabal of people evil people
I just think there are institutions in
the world which control certain things
and they control information and there's
certain things you're not allowed to say
and you're not allowed to question I
don't believe that so yeah you don't
believe that exactly yeah so and covet
is one of them the fact that anyone who
stands up and says anything against uh
the World Health Organization or uh says
that covet is a liar is a scam is
silenced okay I think I find that very
suspicious or even questions
v-h-o yeah the World Health Organization
lied they lied repeatedly so everything
about the World Health Organization is a
lie everything they say about covet is
alive if you're gonna have everything
not everything okay not everything well
so far well we let's look at it from the
beginning right remember when when the
World Health Organization first
identified coven right so the reason I
never believed in covet from the start
the reason I believe the whole thing was
a scam is if you have a disease with a
99 survival rate and the one percent of
people who get sick get the same
symptoms as other diseases flu or
pneumonia Etc how will the World Health
Organization identify such a disease
instantly they wouldn't so it's been
around for a long time it was around for
a long time before any restrictions or
any lockdowns so I I thought about this
just logically and I thought well the
World Health Organization
they would never have identified it
instantly so I didn't trust them from
this star then at the beginning you
remember all these people were dropping
dead in China remember these people were
dropping dead on the street in China
December yeah December 19th have you
seen anyone drop dead no no one seen
anyone drop dead so they they propagated
it in China to try and elaborate to try
and create fear right they they did
create fear so they had these people
dropping dead in the street and then it
spreads out I don't know if you've seen
Wuhan China recently there's a video of
a pool party in New Han China I'll
introducing and put it in two weeks ago
they had a million people at a pool
party in Wuhan so in China virus is
completely over and gone like yeah I am
reading the chat as much as I can and
here we are still in the west scared of
this virus and we have to go home at a
certain time each day and I don't
believe that's anything to do with the
safety of people I believe that's to do
with the control of people because
anyone with a logical brain knows
sending me home at 10 pm has nothing to
do with a virus that has nothing to do
with the virus so the World Health
Organization have been caught lying
repeatedly at the beginning they said
masks were useless you can Google this
right now the World Health Organization
the beginning of the pandemic said we do
not I love how they pop up proof for
everything he says throughout this whole
podcast what's he mention what does he
mention so far what I messed with just
about that there were people dropping
dead in China and they were showing
these propaganda videos of people just
literally killed over on the street and
in public places that died of covid on
the street we just talked about at
dinner today one of the earlier things
they showed too was this guy who got
like his leg amputated because of kovid
do you remember early on how much they
made you try to fear it it was crazy I
remember when it was still in China you
thought like if you got the virus you
were literally dead you you were just
dead that it was as simple as that and
then I remember hearing like one of the
first cases here like my friends dad's
brother got it and I was like oh man I'm
sorry dude like your dad he's gonna die
I guess and now it's you you look back
at it and you're like they really it was
just it was just a prank it was really
just a prank so there's a really
important book that that I think
everybody should read at some point and
it is called many of you probably have
read it and I expect to see it in the
chat um the prince by Machiavelli and
what Machiavelli does in the in the book
is he outlines all different ways to
take over groups of people so he taught
he he has all these different scenarios
if you're in a nation and you want to
overtake the current power system in the
nation if you want to invade a nation
from uh you know outside if you want to
you know have a revolution and he talks
about all these very specific strategies
that are have been used in politics and
War for centuries I think this was
written in around the 1400s no this is
important I'm listening you just gotta
so
um one of the one of the strategies that
he uses was it was a big favorite of
Hitler's and what they do is you come in
and the way to one way to take over
people is to Inch by Inch by Inch take
something away from them or impose a new
rule yep and so uh let's think of it in
terms of Nazi Germany you know he came
in and it for let's just say you know
first he started talking bad about Jews
and getting people you know against them
then it was you know what just wear the
yellow star then it was
um you know curfews for Jews then it and
just when they get used to it and
they're like all right fine this isn't
so bad this can't possibly get any worse
than a new rule then uh you know your
stores have to close and then this can't
get any worse okay then you all have to
move into the ghetto this one place
where we're gonna congregate all of you
but they all think they're going to get
their homes and their stuff back this
can't get any worse and then they're all
getting loaded onto trains and then
they're showing up at camps and then
they're working them to death but others
can't get any worse and then they're in
the gas chamber like these little things
where you break people down little by
little and you can see it happening in
modern day Society in different ways
that was only you know 75 80 years ago
so that's not even that extreme of an
example but all three recorded history
up until now you can see this done and
this is what happened here stay home
three weeks to flatten the curve then
wear a mask then a second mask and then
curfews take the shot take the shot if
if you don't take the shot then you know
and then people started to push back and
they really started to freak out so they
had to double down take the shot or
you're losing your job take the shot or
you can't come to school or you can't go
to a restaurant you can't go to the
theater you can't do anything and they
just kept implementing and implementing
and implementing but it doesn't work as
well anymore at least in not a modern
day democracy where at some point we all
just throw our hands up and like [ __ ]
you we're living our lives but it's
they're still trying and just read the
book and you're going to be amazed and
disgusted by how you see I'm going to
read that that's how you see it that was
a great rant you just wanna I'm not
gonna lie that was fire you know what
I'm saying okay I'm saying I'm saying
look at the reasoning behind everything
that they're doing like think about
everything that someone says comes with
a motive okay so think about the hidden
motive and think about the same people
that are telling you the different
things the same people that are
promoting covid are promoting climate
change they're promoting taking away
your guns they're promoting all the
stuff that's ultimately here to just
control you so when you realize like
what something's a scam then look into
the other stuff you know what I mean
like why why are all the shootings
happening is there is there a convenient
reasoning behind them that they can
leverage that to use against you and
take away your guns not going to go too
deep down that rabbit hole yeah I don't
think that why did 9 11 happen do you
think that that was really just a couple
a couple dudes in the Middle East coming
over and blowing up the the some of the
most important buildings in the world
with [ __ ] box cutters on an airplane
I think is this what we really are gonna
believe I don't know I you know what I
do believe I do believe that they were
there we were attacked by political
enemies but I think that those are other
questions that I'm willing to explore
with you but I I don't want to turn into
crazy conspiracy theorists either that's
not that crazy look up try to find try
to find anything about a plane hitting
the Pentagon try to find something about
it let's do it let's do a whole uh let's
do a whole night about that because
there are there are theories that you
have that you've explored that I haven't
seen before and I I am absolutely
open-minded to hearing different things
it comes my first video strike but I I I
want to hear it but I'm not gonna just
jump in the deep end on these theories
okay we're getting Machiavelli to death
by our government they also I know right
imagine we do lose a second amendment
Amendment it's over it's literally it's
over from there we do not recommend
lockdowns they said both of these things
on their website I remember and remember
this is true this is true they said we
don't recommend mess because masks are
are limited and they're available only
for doctors I remember this they there's
a lot of studies and one of them was on
the World Health Organization website
saying that masks are ineffective as a
whole and the point is that if you have
a mask on you touch your face you touch
the mask you move the mask you breathe
in the mask that if you're going to get
the virus and get the virus the masses
are ineffective as a whole this is the
point so the World Health Organization
has reversed its role in reverses
position repeatedly and what it's done
is it's repeat it's changed its position
in line with politics so I believe the
whole Corona scam is political like
everything in the world is political 100
all political almost about controlling
people so me as an individual I refuse
to wear a mask and I say to everybody
don't wear your mask but this is
yesterday this is my opinion
my opinion okay YouTube why opinion is
that nobody should wear a mask my
opinion is that everybody should think
for themselves and you should not be
controlled by the information centers of
the world which say that you're not
allowed to question anything and you
should be able out to question Corona
you should look in my opinion in my
opinion is that I respect the law but I
can say anything about I can say it's a
bad law but I respect it okay this is my
opinion go ahead it's actually really
good that we disagree on this issue
because they make the video far more
interesting but law as a whole the idea
of law is common good right if I believe
there's common good for a law then I'll
respect it but if someone's going to
pass a law with absolutely no proof and
I don't believe there's any common good
I'm going to think for myself and say no
I don't want to go home at 10 pm you
cannot tell me viruses have time and
there's no one alive who's going to
believe that and the World Health
organization's constant flip-flopping
and all they're lying about Corona and
they've been caught changing their mind
about things on time time and time again
they don't know anything every month
fact is what we do know about Corona is
one of the coronaviruses along with the
common cold and the flu it's very very
harmless what was the other thing we
were just talking about that the
government completely lied to people and
in their head out the other side well
we're just talking about something do
you remember I know somebody here just
mentioned Epstein was that it that they
just brushed that under the rug oh yeah
oh yeah there's a black book with all
all the Democrats you know fully well
they have the list of everybody that was
involved in the Epstein oh my God that
is the most corrupt [ __ ] ever control he
had it was insane
they would still be talking about that
on the news every single day to this
moment but we don't even know as they
should if he was on it like if he was on
it yes we should be talking about raping
gross people who are in power and and
and having sex with 14 year old girls
like ah gross
survival rate is 99.8 right you're
locking people in their houses you're
destroying people's businesses their
life work because yeah because of fear
and they're propagating fear on a virus
with a 99.8 survival rate and they're
doing it by saying it's going to kill
your grandma it's going to kill your
grandma every time you ever visit your
grandma you had a disease fear yeah fear
and the traditional response emotional
response when emotions points we have
when people us animals have an emotion
when I was when I was still in high
school this was like the peak of covet
and I remember I was one of the only
people still questioning this [ __ ] and
I'm asking my physics teacher questions
I'm like dude this doesn't make sense
bro and it's like well there's some kids
here who live with their grandparents
gee now we're here they still live with
their grandparents bro nothing's changed
since then the virus is still out there
what has changed you know like they've
made it so if you're against the vaccine
or you don't want to take it you're the
enemy you are the enemy if you don't
want to take the vaccine you and you
don't care about those grandmas they
literally said this they said this I
care very much about my 82. my teachers
were telling me I told her I'm not
taking the vaccine not taking it it's
nothing you what I'll do is if you
really want because she's nervous I will
test before seeing her at the time she's
all backed up she doesn't even care
anymore but I you know yeah before I
come I'll make sure I take a test mom
even though we also know that these
tests have uh really high false negative
rates so these at home tests you want to
give a quick shout out um make sure you
guys join the Discord in my bio if
videos get taken down I post them there
and I'm also posting stuff on Rumble so
make sure you stay in touch with me
outside of just YouTube because if we're
reacting to stuff like this it's you
know it's pretty likely that it you know
who knows how long it'll stay up and
when you want to control people the
first thing you do is you convince them
there's an outside enemy right yeah you
look at North Korea the reason North
Korea the reason dictator has so much
control is because he says America's
coming to get us America's coming to get
us if there's no outside and Hitler did
you can't control people so the outside
enemies now this virus right tribalist
and we have to do anything we're told no
matter how stupid it is you can sit
there and eat your dinner no problem
talk with your friends no problem I can
kiss the girl next to me no problem but
when I stand up to go piss I have to put
a mask on and I have to walk in there
and I have to take a piss with my mask
on I have to come back and take my mask
off again and sit down I'm not gonna do
whatever I want again do you remember
when some cities require that you have a
mask on the whole time while you're in a
restaurant there was this it was sort of
a flash in the pan Rule and and you were
just supposed to take a bite and then
put your mask back on on in between
bites even while you were sitting at a
table they shut down outdoor dining
because of covid Outdoors it's it's
crazy man it's it's insane and people
were doing it I was like [ __ ] you I'm
not going to a restaurant and acting
like a like an inmate following rules at
a restaurant it was so so so ridiculous
and that kind of went away fast because
even even the most like hardcore covert
covert Believers and the ones that
really bought everything that the
government put out even they were like
this is stupid and they didn't want to
do it yeah and it's obvious that they
wanted fear out of you from the start I
mean the videos they showed initially
were literally were people dropping dead
on the streets they were showing young
people dying from covid when it was if
you had any other thing going on wrong
with you you could have died in a car
crash had coveted in your system and it
would have been a covet deck and then
they'd post 22 year old dies from covid
you know like this is why you really
need to stay home and stay safe anyone's
anyone's that danger to this complete
[ __ ] means an individual I like to
resist because I've seen what's happened
in history and a government has never in
history taken power and given it back
and every time they've taken powers for
the same reasons under the guise of
safety the virus is terrorists it's an
enemy it's this it's that there's
something coming don't you need to join
the Army me without thinking just put
the mask on listen don't worry 10 p.m go
home the virus is out at 10 pm and these
same people who are making these laws
are disobeying these laws I think the
Romanian politicians got caught there's
a picture on Facebook right of them
sitting around in close proximity
smoking cigars during with so these
people making the laws don't obey them
so the people who make the laws know
what about the same people making the
laws about climate change and everything
going around on their private jets oh
how much they care about the environment
you don't give a [ __ ] about the
environment man these people are the
biggest Hypocrites ever there are these
uh elected officials dancing out during
where they were supposed to everybody
was supposed to be in masks at all times
in public places and they were out
dancing dancing and boogieing and having
a great time in each other's faces and
then the video leaked and they got
caught and she goes well you know Tony
Tony came on so how to dance that was
her defense that she really liked you
know they wanted us they came on she
really liked that song so oh dude my
Mask doesn't matter when Tony there's no
covered when Tony Tony Tony's on 2020
you couldn't have you couldn't have
Thanksgiving with your family because of
kovid they told you that you couldn't
have [ __ ] family over for
Thanksgiving because of the scandemic
because of the flu I can't believe
people still believe it too they look
back at all of the the lunacy and
they're like um I'm glad I followed
those rules
[Music]
as you think [ __ ] cracking the first
shot I'd rather riding on the wall won't
last long yeah the feelings
[Music]